Hobbs Gomez my name's baby that was an
intro anyway welcome to nether it's a
game about surviving we all know I would
survive I think I should be black just
for camouflage sake what hue she do it
he's so [ __ ] paranoid calm down Bob
yes her name is Bob whoa see you get
right into the game that's that's cool I
have a knife and I have a tree up my ass
so there's some sort of apocalypse and
it seems to be every man for himself
at least at the moment this is pretty
atmospheric I like it let's go up here
see what happens alright now that I have
a better view
maybe we can decide where to go oh god
what the [ __ ] is that that is the
biggest pimple I have ever seen holy
[ __ ] that's disgusting we should try and
make it to that amber lamps yes
cigarettes seriously that's what you
want to find next to in amber lamps yes
ammo yes what else do we got oh god he
doesn't see me dizzy oh what the hell
he's having fun is he
well I'm glad someone is enjoying their
apocalypse what the [ __ ]
explosive diarrhea will change people I
am shaking my ass off
nice now I'm stuck and the weather is
getting spooky uh help hello
oh god everything is shaking I think I
should make a twerking yoke but I got
nothing really okay we lost our
character he died twerking oh god I see
something what the [ __ ] is that sound
Oh what the [ __ ] is that sound coming
from I don't panic
whatever would a smart person do pee in
their mouth no that's not what okay
let's just get the loot Oh God and get
out what deaf [ __ ] is that [ __ ] sound
oh god what - oh God um nope nope nope
nope oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god damn you're all ugly
oh [ __ ] they're so [ __ ] many oh god
don't that cycle that's I call that
cycle that's like old ethical backup
spot I'm sat on why okay they can dance
we can dance
just run don't look back don't look back
don't look back up back don't look back
that doesn't sound very good
kick it up I'm not dad I'm not dad stop
oh stop pretty [ __ ] bad aren't I
so much training
new character new deaths and I would be
pretty good at castrating people look at
this whoa how cool is that
oMFG F crunches bangs sweet huh a cat
No why the [ __ ] uh Gooden [ __ ]
Freeman
oh gosh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not
those [ __ ] its officers isn't it I
think what oh oh you should end you're
so [ __ ] dead you piece of [ __ ] oh god
there's two of them isn't it
help help help innocent Puetz innocent
I'm innocent I'm innocent
oh god oh god I have a [ __ ] group of
teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle where are
you I got my bro bar oh god the keys to
this what da [ __ ] are you serious I just
got this crowbar I just got it where the
[ __ ] did you even can from let me eat my
potato chips and I'll be on that's not
how you hide away my headphones are
foldable oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] my
teleport e and I see four funny a table
okay okay he thinks he's cool that's his
problem
that's his problem
yours I'm indeed a bluff ah leave me the
[ __ ] alone
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much I don't want it I don't want
to get a [ __ ]
I hated myself but I think we're fine
I'm going to the top and I gotta eat
those potato chips up my ass no you're
no wait okay let's just [ __ ] hide
someone learned that [ __ ] to me
Oh oh god oh god oh god I'm always God
what that really feels nice nice we
[ __ ] made it
hi [ __ ] five let's go to safe haven
others people hi friends
can I have some health please no no no
no no no no don't do it marriage
now we must carefully select our route I
would say just [ __ ] go there alright
let's do it now remember bids there
could be dangerous around any corner Joe
glued your guard ok crowbar whatever you
say man I'm hard as a [ __ ] rock baby
um oh my [ __ ] god so much crunchy
Ben's is that the only existing potato
chips in this universe because I'm ok
with it I love ho chi minh's I love
crunching unban sighs now what okay
we're getting there
we're getting there so far we got a lot
of potato chips and a lot of spirit
isn't that right baby boo
all right well hold on pets is obviously
a trap there must be more potato chips
Harry no by the [ __ ] is the potato chips
oh god damn oh you [ __ ] up now pants
oh what the [ __ ]
hey man have you seen Oh Jack Madonna
fine you can get it to see enjoy your
target him applause no crow
he took my crowbar that son of a [ __ ]
here's a badass had to like I was
chasing shy suffice and [ __ ] by sec
okay there's an escort over there let's
try and do some [ __ ] quests got a
Miss bro bar but I guess I'm stuck with
you mister knife yes mister [ __ ]
knife I can't think about any more great
I'm gonna find that guy I'm gonna cut
his balls off and I gotta save bro bar
that is our goal
say bro bar oh my all my potato chips
oh but locks hahaha oh he's gonna regret
[ __ ] with me Oh God so close but so
far away it's gonna take three [ __ ]
years for us to get there
goddamn stealth build stealth and
self-pity
no one sees me cuz I'm singing that
stupid song all night long I love my
ring my song while I'm wearing my tongue
I'm doing my step song all night long
baby up just break down to me I got Gaga
ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
whoa what what what bro max what I don't
know what that is but I am love it can
food my favorite type of food ammo and
[ __ ] nice I can like throw it at enemies
and be like hey that's almost as if I
kill you oh wow we moved about to 1
centimeter on the [ __ ] map alright
there's an escort now it's over there we
don't have a [ __ ] but life is [ __ ] isn't
it Oh jab
laughs Shawn oh god no don't tell me
that he's on me ah come on
Oh table teleportation I got him I got
him
oh if he bleeds ow ow that means you can
stab his dick out right if I hate your
[ __ ] yeah that's right that's right I
kill you
alright let's make it to ace going but
only my hair will look good that's
pretty good I just keep going [ __ ] yeah
I'm actually starting to like the game
it's it's [ __ ] neg sweet it's a
little empty sometimes but once [ __ ]
goes down and goes down the [ __ ]
toilet and then you flush and then
Europe Oh job level whoa job luck what
what what what what what who touched me
ha ha
what how did I even huh I was level -
okay escort is close this time around
nice yes yes
Oh God I got his ticking what does that
even mean what am I supposed to take it
what the [ __ ]
uh-oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] thing attracting stuff that
would be yes
just slowly around the back let's
[ __ ] teleport it's not fair just got
it
ah yeah I can I am smart you're smarter
than young no you're not you're [ __ ]
god [ __ ] - don't do that that would be
gross I'm not into bestiality that's not
even [ __ ] funny okay cool
how how the [ __ ] did they know Oh bro
this was some big office famous for
being tall and dark and gray just like
my penis there were lots of important
things happen there
just like my nothing okay cool okay if
you didn't blink so [ __ ] much
maybe I wouldn't be I never know why I
had you I should just [ __ ] drop you
and go on with my life I can't let you
do that appearance but okay I'm gonna go
go really quick this is Reggie Gary
tabing appears a son of a I'm so bad at
this [ __ ] game alright new game new
escort let's not [ __ ] this up I'm not a
bad gamer I'm a hardcore gamer okay I
almost finished a Xcel's II what what
yes yes I would like to
Oh what is happening what is going on
this [ __ ] I can't I'm sorry I can't
what the [ __ ] not [ __ ] babies can touch
me
yeah oh god oh god my bike is oh damn
whoa [ __ ] you you killed mr. bang pow
pow pow pow pow pow pow
that little [ __ ] I hear me dude
agilent's well at least they can't take
my bike I'm so [ __ ] bad at this game
those people were waiting for people to
pick up the loot package those little
[ __ ] dicks don't even talk to me you
dirty [ __ ]
what is that what is that noise that can
that cannot what is that oh god II got
eyes of lasers kill watch as Heiser
license raj - life so sorry yes okay we
purge that [ __ ] i wonder when we is so
jolly happy
that does not sound good for me that is
not the nether searches and oh thank god
well I can't even see anything that's
it's not food shut up shut up shut up
Chuck oh [ __ ] my ass out don't [ __ ] my
oh he's come to rescue oh god okay I'll
deal with a tiny one you deal with it
one [ __ ] me oh god he has so much [ __ ]
oh god no he died to rescue me and then
I I feel so terrible
fill in my
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you slap that I'll on the
floor slab dad gave me some Oh laughs
dad chill your ass is [ __ ] dead you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I will [ __ ]
you over like I [ __ ] your mom's ass
yes I did yes I did I don't care if
she's ugly oh really more [ __ ] hell
no not now I came so [ __ ] bar not
gonna [ __ ] die now not gonna [ __ ]
die now not gonna [ __ ] die now it's
the last [ __ ] thing I'll ever [ __ ]
[ __ ] not gonna [ __ ] dart out your
piece of [ __ ] hope you enjoyed this
episode
leave a like if you're dead I liked it a
lot that's the sky Cumbria today I suck
at this game but it was fun anyway right
haha southwest love you
you